keine verschärfung aber auch keine
lockerung wir dürfen jetzt nicht
leichtsinnig sein
wir dürfen uns nicht in sicherheit
wiegen sagt die bundeskanzlerin und
appelliert an alle in der korona krise
durchzuhalten
mehr solidarität in europa fordert ezb
chefin lagarde von den euro-ländern die
ringen weiter wie das konkret aussehen
kann
und achtung fälschung bei kriminelle bei
den soforthilfen betrügen stoppt
nordrhein westfalen die zuschüsse für
unternehmen in not
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara e
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
gründonnerstag wir müssen konsequent
bleiben und durchhalten
das ist die ernüchternde botschaft der
kanzlerin zu ostern die lage sei
weiterhin fragil
wir sollten froh sein dass derzeit keine
verschärfungen der beschränkung nötig
sei und wir werden noch lange mit dieser
pandemie leben müssen
thomas reichert hat mir das land ist im
stillstand und soll es erstmal bleiben
auch wenn die infektionszahlen hoffnung
machen
bundeskanzlerin merkel fordert heute
eindringlich auch über die feiertage zu
hause zu bleiben
abstand zu halten wir haben in den
letzten wochen gemeinsam viel kraft
bewiesen und jetzt kommt es gerade vor
diesem osterwochenende darauf an darin
nicht nachzulassen
es gilt unverändert sie schützen all die
menschen für die das virus eine tödliche
gefahr bedeuten kann wann und wie aber
kann es lockerungen geben
gesundheitsminister sparen hat
erleichterungen in aussicht gestellt
wenn der positive trend sich sofort
setzte ostern werde eine weggabelung
sein an der sich das entscheide
wir werden noch über lange strecken über
wochen und monate auf manches
liebgewonnene verzichten müssen
auf festivals auf den besuch von clubs
oder auf manches volksfest dieser
verzicht tut auch weh
dieser verzicht ist aber auch notwendig
manchen dauert das zu lange die fdp will
wirtschaft und öffentliches leben
schnellstmöglich wieder herstellen
die afg das land sogar schon nach ostern
wieder hochfahren
weil wir der meinung sind dass
inzwischen die finanziellen
wirtschaftlichen psychischen
kollateralschäden größer sind als die
gesundheitsschäden eine behutsame
rückkehr zur normalität nach ostern das
fordert auch nrw-ministerpräsident
laschet ich überzeugt das argument dass
das dass die deutschen in den letzten
wenigen wochen gelernt haben worauf es
ankommt und die kontakt verbote und die
distanz und den abstand und die
hygieneregeln einer
am nächsten mittwoch wollen bund und
länder gemeinsam beraten
dann soll sich zeigen welche lockerungen
wann möglich sind
entscheidend ist ob und wie lange die
bürger das alles mitmachen matthias
fornoff ist bei mir mit dem aktuellen
politbarometer guten abend matthias
bouten haben wie kommt das
krisen-management der bundesregierung an
naja fast drei viertel der deutschen
sagen dass die maßnahmen die den alltag
einschränken so genau richtig sind
entsprechend positiv ist die bewertung
des krisenmanagements kanzlerin merkel
macht ihre arbeit gut finden 80 prozent
die bundesregierung insgesamt macht ihre
sache in der korona krise gut sagen
sogar 88 prozent
klar dass sich das auf die politische
stimmung auswirkt wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die union auf
35 prozent plus 2 die spd auf 17 prozent
ebenfalls +2 nach den starken verlusten
vor zwei wochen bleibt die fdp bei 10
prozent fdp 5 -1 linke 7 minus 1 grüne
- 2 die massiven einschränkungen gelten
seit fast drei wochen bekommen die leute
damit klar
das belastet mich stark das sagen etwa
40 prozent der deutschen
und das ist interessanterweise weniger
als vor zwei wochen
wir haben dann gefragt in welchen
bereichen denn die einschränkungen
zuerst gelockert werden sollten
in schulen und kitas sagen 45 prozent
erstmal sollen läden und geschäfte
wieder öffnen finden 37 prozent
das kontaktverbot als erstes aufheben
wollen 14 prozent zwei prozent wünschen
sich dass die einschränkungen zuerst
beim sport gelockert werden
das alles aber sollte nicht schon am 20
april stattfinden sondern zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt findet eine mehrheit
großes verständnis frei wird dankeschön
matthias sondern das komplette
politbarometer mit matthias gibt es im
heute journal um 22 uhr oder natürlich
jederzeit online unter zdf heute
ausschlaggebend für mögliche lockerungen
sind die zahlen aktuell sind nach
erhebungen der johns hopkins universität
in deutschland 114 1257 infizierte durch
tests bestätigt davon sind 46.300
bereits genesen die zahl der todesfälle
in verbindung mit profit 19 beträgt 2349
die ausbreitung des virus verlangsamt
sich weiter
der zeitraum in dem sich die infizierten
zahl verdoppelt liegt inzwischen bei
15,9 tagen das alles bezieht sich auf
erkannte infektion
die dunkelziffer ist wohl sehr viel
höher das lässt auch eine aktuelle
studie aus rheinsberg vermuten dass ist
der landkreis der nach einer
karnevalsveranstaltung sehr früh und
sehr heftig betroffen war ralph goldmann
fast zwei wochen lang haben die forscher
hier in dieser schule blutproben und
abstriche der bevölkerung in der zwölf
eineinhalb tausend einwohner gemeinde
gangelt untersucht sie wollten
herausfinden wie hat sich das corona
virus hier ausgebreitet getestet wurden
auch einwohner ohne jegliche symptome
1000 machten mit und das erste
zwischenergebnis von 500 gibt anlass zur
hoffnung denn es hat sich herausgestellt
schon 15 prozent der menschen hier sind
und waren bereits mit corona infiziert
manche haben es noch nicht einmal
bemerkt das bedeutet auch dass 15
prozent der bevölkerung in der gemeinde
gangelt sich nicht mehr mit saas pukki 2
derzeit infizieren können
und dieser 15 prozentige anteil der
bevölkerung bedeutet auch eine gewisse
verlangsamung in der ausbreitung die
dunkelziffer derjenigen die die
infektion schon hinter sich haben und
damit immunisiert sind könnte also
deutlich größer sein als bislang
angenommen
daraus folgern die forscher dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit an der krankheit zu
sterben in der region deutlich geringer
ist als derzeit für ganz deutschland
befürchtet die zahl der insgesamt
infizierten im kreis heinsberg sei
rückläufig so der landrat und sei aber
noch nicht über den berg
wir haben zumindest zahlen die wirklich
mut machen und man sieht dann auch dass
maßnahmen greifen und ich erwarte auch
dass das bezogen auf das land auch in
den nächsten tagen die kurven flachen ab
der fall sein wird
nächste woche werden auch die gäste der
karnevalssitzung getestet die ein
infektionsherd gewesen sein soll
die forscher erhoffen sich dadurch
erkenntnisse darüber wie sich das virus
dort genau verbreitet hat in mecklenburg
vorpommern hat ein gericht erstmals
einschränkungen im kampf gegen die
korona epidemie gestoppt die einwohner
des landes dürfen jetzt doch an den
ostertagen ausflüge an ihre küsten oder
sehen unternehmen
das hatte die landesregierung eigentlich
verboten
die entscheidung des
oberverwaltungsgerichts schwerin ist
allerdings nur vorläufig das urteil in
der hauptsache steht noch aus touristen
aus anderen bundesländern müssen
weiterhin draußen bleiben um die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie zu
bewältigen braucht es europäische
solidarität da sind fast alle eu-staaten
einig wie die aber aussehen soll darüber
wird gestritten ezb chefin christine
lagarde äußerte sich nun in einem
gastbeitrag im general anzeiger
wenn nicht alle länder wieder
vollständig genesen werden die anderen
darunter leiden
solidarität ist also im grunde genommen
eigeninteresse vor einer verengung der
debatte auf europäische corona bonds
also gemeinsame schulden wankt er sie
jedoch anne gellinek berichtet
polizeikontrollen im brüsseler
europaviertel ausgangssperre keiner
kommt rein
die eu finanzminister sind gleich
weggeblieben per videoschalte suchen sie
am abend erneut nach einem kompromiss
wie kann europas wirtschaft nach der
krise angekurbelt werden
euro gruppenchef und verhandlungsführer
mario center no mit einem dramatischen
appell
es gibt keine erste klasse passagiere
entweder wir gehen gemeinsam unter oder
wir schwimmen zusammen dies ist ein
echter notfall ein notfall dem die eu
mit einem paket aus drei maßnahmen
begegnen will
kredite aus dem euro-rettungsfonds esm
der europäischen investitionsbank und
das europäische kurzarbeit
zusammen über 500 milliarden euro
strittig aber noch immer die bedingungen
unter denen die mittel fließen sollen
die niederlande geben europas mister no
sie wollen geld aus dem rettungsschirm
esm nur dann auszahlen wenn die
betroffenen länder sie direkt zur
bekämpfung des virus nutzen
andernfalls verlangen sie strenge
sparprogramme was wir nicht akzeptieren
ist dass gelder aus dem rettungsschirm
esm zur stärkung der wirtschaft
eingesetzt werden italien und andere
südeuropäer wehren sich gegen die
koppelung von krediten an reformen und
verlangen mehr solidarität der reichen
nordeuropäer
der deutsche finanzminister glaubt dass
eine einigung möglich ist
wir wollen hier nicht abstrakt über
politik reden sondern darüber wie wir
das richtige tun in eine sehr
schwierigen und anstrengenden zeit
verzweifelte suche nach einem kompromiss
vielleicht braucht er noch eine lange
nacht
diese einigung wäre ein so wichtiges
signal für europa stefan leifert in
brüssel wie weit ist das rettungspaket
hat sich in den letzten stunden und
minuten verhaltener optimismus
breitgemacht zwar ist diese video
schalte der finanzminister immer wieder
stunde um stunde verschoben worden sie
hat auch immer noch nicht begonnen aber
das ist diesmal eher ein gutes als ein
schlechtes zeichen denn der euro
gruppenchef hat versucht möglichst viele
vorgespräche zu führen
um diesmal anders als beim letzten mal
mit möglichst viel konsens und möglichst
wenig dissens in dieses treffen zu gehen
die gute nachricht ein großer
streitpunkt ist schon mal abgeräumt der
streit um die euro bonds der iss vertagt
worden
es spielt im moment erstmal überhaupt
keine rolle mehr was bleibt ist die
streitfrage zu welchen bedingungen
kredite des euro rettungsfonds esm
vergeben werden sollen das ist vor allem
ein streit zwischen rom und den haag und
jetzt wird eine formulierung gesucht die
beides deutlich macht zum einen das
keinem land einfach bedingungslos geld
hinterhergeworfen wird zum anderen aber
auch deutlich macht dass es möglich ist
schnell und unkompliziert an geld zu
kommen hier in brüssel haben sich manche
über die härte der niederländer
gewundert wenn es in den nächsten
stunden gelingt diesen widerstand zu
brechen dann ist eine einigung möglich
also die stimmung hier verhaltener
optimismus dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus brüssel stefan leifert
die zahl der
weltweit nachgewiesenen infektionen mit
dem corona virus hat die marke von 1,5
millionen überschritten
im besonders betroffenen italien
zeichnet sich dabei langsam eine
entschärfung der lage ab mehr als
140.000 infizierte doch die zahl neuer
todesfälle bleibt konstant in frankreich
hingegen zeigt sich trotz strenger
auflagen noch keine trendwende beim
mittlerweile gut 83.000 infizierten gibt
es bereits fast 11.000 todesfälle stand
vor einer halben stunde die folge eines
schlecht vorbereiteten
gesundheitssystems wie thomas walde
berichtet wenn emanuel makro sich in
diesen tagen bei praktikern in der
korona krise umhört wie in dieser klinik
nördlich von paris dann begegnet ihm
eine klage
wir haben ein großes problem mit
schutzkleidung das ist das große problem
derzeit wir hatten selbst versucht hier
in der region eine lösung zu finden
vor einem halben jahr oder jahr dachten
wir alle solch material ist nicht so
wichtig das war idiotisch und plötzlich
sitzen wir in der patsche auch tests
kommen nur langsam voran die zahl der
neuinfektionen flacht sich nur
schleppend ab die zahl der toten steigt
deutlich die opposition sagt frankreich
stehe im vergleich schlecht da erhöhte
sie haben es in china gesehen und in
südkorea testen hilft deutschland will
demnächst hunderttausende tests pro tag
machen und denkt darüber nach seine
auflagen ab dem 19 april zu lockern
gemeinden versuchen es im alleingang so
verlangt von jedem bürger draußen eine
maske zu tragen wie sie baut banker ab
damit sich niemand setzen kann
paris verbietet tagsüber zu joggen die
polizei hat landesweit 570.000
strafzettel verteilt eine lockerung ist
nicht in sicht
es ist die zeit der ausgangssperre und
die wird dauern
und so stellt frankreich sich darauf ein
dass die ausgangssperre verlängert wird
bis weit über ostern hinaus
in die usa einem weiteren brennpunkt der
krise
dort ist das sozialsystem so schwach
entwickelt dass arbeitnehmern neben der
gesundheitsgefahr auch der finanzielle
absturz tot
6,6 millionen menschen haben in der
vergangenen woche einen erstantrag auf
arbeitslosenhilfe gestellt
damit haben in den usa wegen krone
inzwischen rund 17 millionen menschen
ihren job verloren
ines trams landauf landab in den usa
lange schlangen an den essensausgaben
dort wo lebensmittel kostenlos verteilt
werden die wirtschaft runtergefahren
viele menschen ohne arbeit auch hier in
los angeles essen auf dem tisch mit
einem mal nicht mehr selbstverständlich
auch die mittelschicht betroffenen viele
sind zum ersten mal hier
ich habe in einer rechtsanwaltskanzlei
gearbeitet es läuft das
bewerbungsverfahren für hilfe aber das
dauert monate
dies aber passiert jetzt diese woche ein
erneuter rekord sprung der
arbeitslosenzahlen sie schnellten um
weitere 6,6 millionen hoch insgesamt
haben sich in der korona krise fast 17
millionen arbeitslos gemeldet zahlen die
präsident trump verleiten könnten die
wirtschaft möglichst schnell wieder
hochzufahren schließlich ist er im
wahlkampf
er wird annehmen dass eine
wiederbelebung der wirtschaft der weg
ist seinen konkurrenten joe biden zu
schlagen in die richtung wird er druck
machen und dann ist es an den
gesundheitsexperten vor sich zu predigen
und ihn zu bremsen
derweil halten sich viele mit nebenjobs
über wasser
auch der ehemalige vertreter maik
gärtnert jetzt während der bewerbung
nach bewerbung raus ich höre aber immer
nur wir lehnen jede offene position auf
eis alle rückrufe für marketing jobs
sagen wir stehen derzeit nicht an mein
optimismus weicht gerade den pessimismus
am morgen scheiterte ein zweites
hilfspaket für kleine geschäftsinhaber
im us-senat die parteien konnten sich
nicht einigen
die bundesregierung versucht
massenarbeitslosigkeit durch kurzarbeit
zu vermeiden
jeder dritte betrieb in deutschland hat
inzwischen kurzarbeit an
nicht rund 650.000 unternehmen aus allen
branchen mit einem schwerpunkt bei
gastronomie und handel
die gewerkschaften fordern inzwischen
das staatliche kurzarbeitergeld zu
erhöhen von 60 auf 80 prozent des
nettoeinkommens einer köchin etwa
blieben sonst gerade mal 900 euro im
monat zum leben
auch die lufthansa hat massive probleme
der konzern verliere jede stunde etwa
eine million euro sagt lufthansa chef
carsten spohr statt 350 tausend
passagieren pro tag befördere die
airline jetzt nur noch 3000 ohne
staatliche unterstützung werde die
lufthansa die krise nicht überstehen
seit ende märz stehen viele maschinen
still geparkt am flughafen frankfurt
kriminelle nutzen die korona krise für
ganz neue betrügereien nicht nur an der
haustür sondern auch im netz besonders
dreist bei dem soforthilfen für solo
selbstständige und kleinunternehmer
nordrhein westfalen hat die auszahlung
dieser sofort helfen jetzt gestoppt weil
cyberkriminelle sie mit gefälschten
antrag seiten offenbar zusichern leiten
konnten peter böhmer hat die details die
korona soforthilfe schnelles geld für
notleidende unternehmer schnelles geld
für betrüger nordrhein westfalen teilte
heute mit dass sich cybercrime täter die
daten von antragstellern besorgt haben
um dann mit diesen daten selbst anträge
zu stellen
das land hat nun die soforthilfe bestand
es sind jetzt sich tausende von
rechtschaffenen menschen die dadurch
nicht die zahlung bekommen die sie
dringend benötigen und das ist eine
echte sauerei der korona soforthilfe
haben viele unternehmer offenbar mit
schlagworten nach der richtigen antrag
seite gesucht und landeten dann auf
webseiten die sich von der richtigen
hier kaum unterschieden die arglos
eingegebenen daten wurden abgefischt um
dann mit ihnen einen offiziellen antrag
zu stellen
dort aber mit kontonummern von
mittelsmännern für die überweisungen der
anteil der täter wurde dann im darknet
in eine
bewährung umgewandelt rückverfolgung
kaum möglich drei bis viertausend fälle
soll es geben es gibt anzeichen dass das
ausländische dienste da beteiligt sind
also dienst im sinne von telefondienste
technische dienste und es spricht
einiges dafür dass osteuropa der
standort da ist drei milliarden euro hat
das land nrw schon an soforthilfen
ausgezahlt fast nur an echte
antragsteller doch das verfahren ist nun
so lange gestoppt bis alle anträge
überprüft sind es wird einige tage
dauern bis mit den auszahlungen wieder
begonnen wird und auch heute gibt es ein
zdf spezial zum thema wer hilft den
ärmsten in der korona krise wie gehabt
um 19.25 direkt nach uns und wenn sie
wissen wollen was überhaupt über die
feiertage erlaubt ist und was nicht
antworten darauf und noch viel mehr gibt
es in unserer zettel freute es so ein
ostern so einen grünen donnerstag gab es
in der jüngeren geschichte der
katholischen kirche noch nicht der papst
feiert die messe zum gedenken an das
letzte abendmahl jesu im leeren
petersdom in rom
in seiner predigt rief franziskus dazu
auf besonders für die heilung der
kranken zu beten
gläubige auf der ganzen welt können im
internet den gottesdienst verfolgen
an diesem grünen donnerstag endet für
christen die 40 tägige fastenzeit das
was der papst gerade erlebt darunter
leiden derzeit auch viele künstler und
musiker das publikum fährt das opernhaus
in stuttgart versucht das beste daraus
zu machen
anna was back berichtet
[Applaus]
ja es ist eine freude für sie endlich
wieder auf der großen bühne der
staatsoper stuttgart zu stehen auch wenn
der zuschauerraum hinterm graben
menschenleer ist das künstlerehepaar
schaut nicht wie gewohnt in die
gesichter des publikums sondern in eine
kamera
man könnte jetzt auch zu hause sitzen
und däumchen drehen aber so sind wir
nicht so ist hier niemand jeder der
auftreten möchte der brennt darauf
wieder vor allem echten publikum spielen
zu dürfen
ihr publikum sitzt jetzt zum beispiel
hier 500 kilometer entfernt im
seniorenzentrum in warendorf oper für
oma ein öffentliches videostream konzert
extra für die menschen die durch die
korona krise besonders isoliert sind
die werden auf lange sicht auch nicht so
schnell wieder vor die tür kommen oder
in die oper und das ist umso wichtiger
dass wir durch kultur die seelen
erreichen und vermitteln europa trotz
bewohner
damit das klappt müssen sie jetzt
ständig neue formate wie dieses finden
und sich gleichzeitig überlegen wie es
weitergeht sei es mit reduziertem
publikum sei es mit medialen
möglichkeiten aber natürlich sind wir
auch jetzt schon kreativ wie man mit
diesem bios umgehen kann und trotzdem
oper machen
die reaktion der zuhörer fehlt den
beiden solisten aber wenigstens können
sie musik so nun an orte bringen wo sie
normalerweise nicht hinkommt
[Musik]
und auch wenn die fußball bundesliga
derzeit ruht einen trainerwechsel gibt
es trotzdem hertha bsc hat labbadia als
cheftrainer eingekauft der 54 jährige
ersetzt interims coach alexander nouri
ostermontag wird labbadia sein erstes
training in der hauptstadt leiten
zuletzt hatte er den vfl wolfsburg bis
in die europa league geführt
beim tabellendreizehnten muss er
zunächst mal im kampf gegen den abstieg
helfen das wetter am karfreitag wird
april frisch im norden sommerlich warm
im süden wie es samstag und über ostern
weitergeht erklärt gleich katjana claus
kleber freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um 10
danke für ihr interesse und ihrem
zuspruch machen sie trotz allem das
beste aus diesen feiertagen alles gute
ihnen und bis morgen wenn sie retten
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute lag ein
kleines schmales und immer schmaler
werden das wolkenband sie über
deutschland gleichzeitig entwickelten
sich nachmittags einige quellwolken im
westen und im süden deutschlands und
auch in der nacht sind noch einige
wolkenfelder unterwegs häufig ist der
himmel aber auch klar und dann wird es
wieder kalt besonders in der lüneburger
heide
da sinken die temperaturen bis minus 1
grad bodenfrost gibt es aber auch in der
uckermark in nordfriesland im emsland
und auch am alpenrand morgen klettern
die temperaturen südwestlich von
niederrhein nordhessischen bergland und
thüringer wald auf 18 bis 25 grad im
norden ist es kühler und besonders an
der see da liegen die höchstwerte nur
bei neun bis elf grad und das liegt an
der wassertemperatur von nord und ostsee
denn beide haben derzeit nur acht grad
wassertemperatur
damit ist auch klar woher der wind weht
nämlich von der kalten see und deswegen
ist das eine nord- bis nordwestwind
morgen jetzt einige quellwolken aber
auch viel sonnenschein am karsamstag
dreht der wind dann auf süd und damit
wird es auch in der kiste etwas wärmer
am ostersonntag erwarten und 16 bis 26
grad
es gibt ein leichtes regen schauer und
gewitterrisiko in den mittelgebirgen und
an den alpen am ostermontag um die
nächste kaltfront mit regen und
gewittern
schönen abend noch